Another possible solution to the IP address space
exhaustion problem is to simply add more bits. This
is the gist of the contribution of the
IPv6 protocol. Here's a picture of the IPv4 protocol
header, and all of the fields shown in
red have basically been removed in IPv6, resulting in
both a much simpler header and addresses that
are much larger. By contrast, here's the IPv6 header.
The IPv6 header provides 128 bits for
both the source and destination IP addresses. Now
the format of these addresses are as follows. Of the 128 bits, the top 48
bits are for the public routing topology,
and we have a 16-bit site identifier. And
finally, a 64-bit interface ID, which effectively
has the 48-bit ethernet address of the interface
plus 16 more bits. Now, the top 48 bits can be broken down further. They include
3 bits for aggregation, 13 bits for a
top level provider, something like a tier one
ISP, 8 reserve bits, and 24 additional bits. Now, note that there are 13 bits in
the top 48 that directly map to the
tier one ISP, meaning that addresses are purely provider-based,
thus changing ISPs would require renumbering.
IPv4 has many claimed benefits. There are
more addresses, the header is simpler,
multihoming is supposedly easier, various aspects of
security are built in, such as the IPv6 crypto extensions. Now despite
all of these benefits, we have yet to see the huge deployment of IPv6 yet.